hoy vamos a hablar de un tema fascinante
cuando pensamos en Africa es
prácticamente imposible abandonar los
'números clichés que sobrevuelan
a nuestro aldedor en ellos, África
aparece siempre como una tierra desolada,
atrasada, catastrófica y pérdida, llena
de  hambre, enfermedades
repúblicas bananeras guerras y
víctimas que otras muchas ocasiones copan por completa nuestra imaginación
Sin embargo, como afinaba Richard Capuchinsky
"Salvo por por el nombre geográfico,
África no existe" para demostrar que en
esta tierra podemos encontrar lugares que nos hacen dejar atrás todas estos perjuicios
hoy nos vamos a esta farsa de las
limitaciones del desierto del Kalahari
hoy BOTSUANA es nuestro destino.
Imaginemos un país en el que sólo
hubiese del tee dos universitarias un
país en el que sólo quince de cada mil
habitantes supiesen leer y escribir un
país del tamaño de España pero con
sólo 20 kilómetros de carreteras.
Imaginemos un país cubierto por
desierto y que no tuviese salida al mar.
Probablemente nuestros augurios sobre el
mismo serían cuanto menos poco
halagüeños.
Si además nos dijesen este país tienen
problemas en el abastecimiento de agua
electricidad que depende de forma
acuciante del ayuda exterior y que sus
vecinos son más bien hostiles,
el panorama nos resultaría peor. Estoy convencido que ninguno de nosotros
apostaría al desarrollo de un país en
el que sólo hubiesen, en la práctica, un
ingeniero y que sus ciudades apenas estuviesen conectadas por carretera. Estoy convencido
prácticamente nos parecería una broma.
Así era Botsuana en 1966: bien lo
podríamos catalogar como un inframundo
de pesadilla y no en vano en el mundo
era uno los diez países
más pobres del planeta.
A tenor de esta descripción estoy
convencido que todos podríamos pensar a
la hora de hablar de mucho no en decenas
de miles de niños hambrientos
deambulando en busca de comida o en unas cuantas escuelas comandadas por
misioneros cooperantes.
Sin embargo nada más lejos de la
realidad. Durante los últimos 50 años,
Botsuana sido uno de las mayores
sorpresas económicas del mundo. Ha sido
uno de los países con mayor crecimiento su Producto Interior Bruto per cápita en
dólares constantes ha crecido de forma
anualizada un 5,9 %. Esto es
,para que nos entendamos, se ha
multiplicado por 15 pero es ¿Esto es
alto o bajo?
Por comparar, durante el mismo período
de tiempo,
la misma cifra se ha multiplicado en
españa por apenas 2, 7 en Bolivia
por 1,5 y en Turquía por 3 con un
si la comparación la realizamos con los
países vecinos de Botsuana el escenario
no es muy diferente incluso si que lo
que queremos es obtener una radiografía
una instantánea de cuerna situación de
Botsuana actualmente en el ranking
internacional
simplemente tenemos que tomar datos del
Fondo Monetario Internacional
así si tomamos el fruto interior bruto
per cápita en paridad de poder
adquisitivo, esto es
excluímos los efectos fruto de los
diferentes índices relativos de precios
nos encontramos que Botsuana se
encuentre por encima de países como
Brasil, Colombia o Tailandia sorprendente
verdad es cierto que este desarrollo
económico ha venido acompañado de un desigualdad muy acuciante hoy Botsuana es
uno de los países más desiguales de todo el planeta. Pero no sería justo por otra
parte olvidar que dicho crecimiento
económico vaya también acompañado de
un desarrollo muy importante los
servicios sociales que ha permitido
excluir a la mayoría de los habitantes
de la pobreza.
así hoy en día Botsuana cuenta con el
mejor sistema educativo del África
subsahariana. Gratuito y universal, tanto
en primaria como en secundaria el 95% de
la población tiene acceso a agua
potable y vida menos de 8 kilómetros de
un centro atención.Claro para
quienes estamos acostumbrados a un nivel
de vida alto
estos datos nos pueden resultar poco
sorprendentes. Pero tanto en África como
los países más pobres no son algo
frecuente.  Botsuana ha sido un éxito
económico pero también social. Ha pasado como a lograr un país tan
pobre tan alejado de las cadenas de
producción internacionales y que
además no tiene salida al mar
conseguir semejante desarrollo parece
casi un milagro sobre todo si tenemos en
cuenta que este país ha sido durante
los últimos años
terriblemente afectados por el sida. No
en vano es el segundo país del mundo con
mayor incidencia de VIH. Según las
estadísticas de la ONU,   el 25%
de su población adulta.
Esto es, 1 de cada 4 personas
padecen dicha patología. Es cierto que
este boom económico de los diamantes
han jugado un papel decisivo. Botsuana
es considerada la mayor potencia del
sector en el mundo. Pero no es menos
cierto que si no hubiese contado unas
instituciones estables inclusivas
nada de esto hubiese sido posible. Son
muchos los casos seguro todos conocemos
algunos de países tremendamente ricos
en recursos naturales que sin embargo
ven cómo su población vive la
auténtica miseria países que son
dirigidos por una élite extractiva.
Esto es una élite cuya única
motivación es perpetuarse en el poder
para esquilmar los recursos nacionales.
Qué  mejor ejemplo para un español que
la Guinea Ecuatorial de Teodoro Obiang.
Guinea Ecuatorial es un país muy rico.
En petróleo es prácticamente un
territorio asentado sobre una balsa de
petróleo. Sin embargo, esta riqueza
no llega sus ciudadanos. Y si, como todos
podemos imaginar, sus gobernantes
están entre los más ricos del mundo.
Por contra en Botsuana sus autoridades
sus líderes políticos pronto dieron
lecciones de responsabilidad.
Así cuando se independizaron en 1966 y
a pesar de que los recursos eran muy
escasos
(como he dicho antes bostuana de no los
diez países más pobres del planeta)
sus gobernantes apostaron por una economía con impuestos bajos y por prohibir la
nacionalización de la propiedad privada
para dar seguridad jurídica y por el
evitar en la medida de lo posible la
emisión de deuda soberana.
Todo esto obligó a priorizar cada
dólar de gasto público.
Así, por ejemplo, las armas no fueron una
prioridad el gobierno de SERETSE KHAMA
consideró que el ejército no era
prioritario y durante más de una
década
Botsuana careció de fuerzas armadas.
Si no había dinero para sanidad, si no
había dinero para escuelas, mucho menos
para armas y soldados.
De la misma forma, tras la independencia,
las autoridades buscaron la
conciliación entre la población blanca
y la población negra. Algo muy diferente a
lo que ocurrió por ejemplo en países
vecinos como Zimbaue. Es precisamente
en este aspecto donde cabe destacar que el propio Seretse Khama se hubiera casado ya
en 1948 con una mujer blanca. Aunque hoy esto nos pueda parecer algo
normal, en aquel momento, fue auténtica
dinamita política.
de hecho las autoridades coloniales, las
autoridades británicas,
prohibieron al matrimonio acceder
durante prácticamente una década al
protectorado. Se puede decir que fueron
exiliados por amor. Pero ¿Podemos
considerar acaso que todo el éxito se
debió a la lección circunstancia de
ser líderes políticos?
¿Esto es una cuestión de suerte donde
los ciudadanos de botrán acertaron con
la legión los políticos? Lo cierto es
que, más allá de esta coincidencia,más
o menos fortuita, o esta supuesta suerte
las instituciones botsuanas se asentaron
sobre la tradición ya precolonial de
corte realista.
Me explico: además del tradicional poder
ejecutivo el poder legislativo y de la
necesaria independencia judicial, en
Botsuana existen también instituciones
tradicionales que refuerzan precisamente
la participación ciudadana y el control
de los poderes públicos.
Así se encuentra la casa de los jefes:
un órgano cuya misión es asesorar al
gobierno en materia de leyes al gobierno
y al parlamento y sobre todo la que
probablemente es el órgano político
más característico de este país.
La KGOTLA es una asamblea donde los
ciudadanos se reúnen para debatir
acerca de los problemas y proyectos que
afectan a la comunidad una asamblea
donde las personas que intervienen tiene
su turno de palabra protegidos y pueden
intervenir con plena libertad.
así no es extraño que la KGOTLA  no
sólo haya permitido reforzar la
participación de los ciudadanos en el
futuro del país convirtiéndose en un
poderoso instrumento de participación
política sino que también es un
órgano de fiscalización de los poderes
públicos de las autoridades de los
políticos.
Por ello no es extraño que en el
índice internacional de percepción de
la corrupción
Botsuana ocupa el puesto 31. Un puesto
mejor que el de países como España,
bueno seguro que a ninguno nos extraña, Israel o Taiwan. Por cierto, en este aspecto,
cabe también destacar que la democracia
de Botsuana es ya la más antigua y
estable del continente africano.
El resultado es evidente
Botsuana: un lugar donde hasta hace 50
años no había siquiera negocios
formales y que padece unas condiciones
geográficas y climáticas muy adversas
es hoy el país más rico, el país menos
corrupto y el segundo país más libre
del áfrica subsahariana. No ha sufrido
ni guerra civil o intervención militar alguna.
Y el crecimiento económico y el
camino a la prosperidad comenzó incluso
antes de descubrir y empezar a
explotar se los yacimientos de diamantes.
La primera mina abrió en el 72 y la
época dorada no llegó hasta la década
los 80. Para alcanzar el éxito el pueblo
botsuano no necesitó recurrir a
revoluciones populares ni a ningún tipo
de dictadura sino apostar puestos en es
inclusiva sustentadas en la democracia
la pluralidad y el respeto a los
derechos de la propiedad. Instituciones
que guardan estabilidad macroeconómica
se comportarán de forma austera y
fomentarán el desarrollo de una pujante
economía de mercado así como la
inversión en la infraestructura
esencial para promover el desarrollo
económico y social. Por delante son
muchos los retos a los que se enfrenta
este país. Entre ellos cabe estacar los
siguientes: en primer lugar la
diversificación de la economía y la
promoción de actividades intensivas en
mano de obra, son puntos clave.
Al fin y al cabo, el desempleo sigue
siendo muy alto y la pobreza continúa
afectando al 20% de la población
En segundo lugar el desarrollo de
infraestructuras que mejoren su
competitividad como el ferrocarril
transcar ahari por la gente la térmica
moro por ebay en tercer lugar la
trajeron de inversión extranjera y la
primera de empresas públicas.
Los retos son muchos y el camino al
primer mundo es aún largo pero si algo
se ha ganado este país de poco más de
dos millones de habitantes es el derecho,
casi la obligación,  de confiar en sus
posibilidades.
Estaremos muy atentos a las novedades
que allí se produzcan y es que, como
puedes ver, más allá de las andanzas de
nuestro Rey emérito con los elefantes
y otros seres vivos del lugar,
Botsuana resulta fascinante.
Si tienes alguna duda o quieres aportar algo, puedes dejar un comentario